abone ol
[Müzik]
Bu
sporda her zaman biz bir tarafta
şampiyonları bir tarafta da ikincileri
konuşuyoruz Aslında bu sporcuların çoğu
Birbirine çok yakın ki fiziksel
tekniksel ve taktiksel becerilere sahip
oluyorlar Ama sadece bir tanesi altın
madalya kazanırken diğeri Gümüş madalya
kazanıyor bir tanesi performans
düşüşleri ne ya da büyük sakatlıklara
rağmen sürece hala aynı kararlılıkla
devam ederken Bir tanesi çok çabuk pas
ediyor Şimdi ben hiç unutmuyorum 2016
Rio olimpiyatlarında Michael phelps'in
bir tane fotoğrafı bize çok büyük bir
hikaye anlatmıştı 200 metre kelebekte
servis kendi kullarına odaklanarak çok
iyi bir şekilde en önde ilerlerken
arkasından Önemli rakiplerinden olan
çatlaklı hemen arkası ikinci sırada
gidiyordu fakat tekbir
Bu sadece saniyelik yan çatlak lo kendi
kullarına bakmak yerine servise baktı ve
film tamamen orada koptu günün sonunda
Michael Phelps altın madalya kazandı
çatlak lo sadece u saniyelik bakış
yüzünden hem Altın madalyayı Hem de ilk
üçü kaçırmış Oldu
oldu tenis tarihinin Hatta bence spor
tarihinin en büyük sporcularından biri
olan Rafael Nadal hem 36 yaşında
olmasına hem de aynı zamanda çok büyük
sakatlıklar geçirmesine rağmen bu
senenin başında ki Avustralya açık'ta
Medvedev ve karşı setlerde 2-0 dan
geriden gelerek toplamda beş saat 28
dakika süren bir maçı kazanıp
şampiyonluk elde etti işte Tam da bu
yüzden bu gibi sporcuların nasıl
başarıları ulaştığını ve nasıl farklar
yarattığını anlamak için ben de kendi
sporculuk kariyerinden sonra bu
yolculuğa çıkmış oldum şu spor inanın
benim her zaman hayatım daydı Yani
kendini bil Ya ben yüzdüm basketbol
oynadığı futbol oynadığı masa tenisi
oynadım ama gerçekten en çok tenisi
sevdim ve her zaman tenis tutkusuyla
yaşadım dokuz yaşında başlayan serüvenim
18 yaşına kadar profesyonel bir tenisçi
olarak devam etti ve bu süreçte Haftanın
altı günü antrenmanlar okuldan
antrenmana yetişme telaşı arkadaşlarım
yazlıkta tatildeyken ve bunu tabii
tadını çıkartırken benim devamlı günde
iki kere çift antrenman yapma çaba
pade de kısık polis oynarken Annem gelip
antreman saati geldi değil beni böyle
oyunun en tatlı en güzel yerinde
antrenmana götürüyordu ya da Hem annem
hem babam çalıştığı için ben yaklaşık 10
yaşlarındayken antrenörüne tek başıma
turnuvaya gidip kendi Bavulumu toplama
sorumluluğuna her zaman ben istemiyordum
gerçekten birey olmayı zamanı en iyi
şekilde Yönetmeyi kendim tek başıma
olmayı ama aynı zamanda takımda
olabilmeyi çok ciddiye alma bu sayesinde
öğrendim Burada gerçekten zaten
zorluklarla baş etmeyi seven bir
çocuktum ve tenisteki en güçlü özelliğin
benim böyle fiziksel ya da tekniksel bir
şey değildi tamamen hırsım ve mücadeleci
ruhunu her zaman bu hırsım sayesinde
asla bir yerlere geldim ve 12 yaşında
inanılmaz bir şey keşfettim E şu an
hatırladım da bile hakikaten böyle
hayattaki ilk ve en büyük keşiflerinden
biri olduğunun farkındayım şimdi
kazanmak ve kaybetmek de olarak çok
eskiden çok erken tanıştığım kavramları
olduğu için ben kendime çocukken hep
nasıl kazanırım bir çok fazla soruyordum
ve bu sorunun cevabına forent derim işte
B kentleri mi Ya da kondisyonlu bir
şekilde geliştirme Bulacağımı sana iken
karşıma çok başka cevaplar çıkmaya
başlamıştı
bıç ünkü maçın içinde rakiplerimi
Moralim acayip kolay boza bildiğini fark
etmiştim böyle puanı kazandıktan sonra
Yes hediye böyle kendi kendime
sevindiğim de ya da basit hata yapsam da
hiçbir şey yokmuş gibi yine devam
edebildiğim de bu karşımda birçok
rakibimin omuzlarını düştüğünü
görüyordum Tabii doğal olarak modelleri
bozulduğu için otomatikman
performansları düştüğünden de ne
yapıyordu bunları Tabii ki devam
ediyorum yapmaya benim için gerçekten
harika bir keşifte Ama tabi ya şimdi
Bunu bilinçli yaptığımı söylemeyeceğim
size doğal olarak tabi ki de bilinçli
bir şekilde yapmıyordum ama seneler
sonra biraz daha kendimi tanıdıktan
sonra fark ettim ki benim o gün yapmaya
çalıştığım şey Aslında bugün mesleğimin
çok büyük bir parçasıymış ve farkında
olmadan ben kendi Mental dayanıklılık
Kasım kullanıyor muşum tabi sonra 18
yaşına geldim şimdi ve tahmin edersiniz
ki Üniversitesi nevi sınavı senesi ile
karşılaştım ve temiz Kariyerim son
bulmuş Oldu oldu Çünkü kendim değil
aslında o günün şartları yüzünden
bırakmıştım tenisi yani sponsorlukları
olmaması Türkiye'de tenisin tam olarak
bir spor olarak görülmemesi ve Bence en
büyük Sebep olarak da Türkiye'de sporun
ta ve meslek olarak kabul edilmemesi
gibi Birçok sebepten dolayı ben temiz
Kaderim sonlandırmayı Ama aklımda her
zaman bir köşesinde olan psikoloji devam
etmeyi tercih ettim tabi şunu da
söylemek gerekiyor ya ailem her zaman
yanımdaydı bu kararında da arkamda larda
Peki tenisi bıraktığım için başarısız
mıydım Bence başarısız değildim ama
gerçekten çok güçlü bir hayal kırıklığı
hissetmiştim Çünkü çocukluğumu çok büyük
bir parçasını ve beni hayatta en çok
besleyen şeyi kaybediyorum bu şekilde
dediğim gibi çok zorlandım ya bu karar
verirken gerçekten zorlandım ama benim
yoluma Bir tık daha rahat devam
edebilmem çok önemli bir sebebi oldu ben
sporcu olarak değil ama bir şekilde
sporu hayatımın başka bir rolle içinde
tutacağıma dair ve Kendime bunu
başarabileceğimi dair bir söz verdim
burada inanın o gün hani spor hayatına
nasıl tutacağım dair en ufak bir fikrim
bile O
benim sporcusu başlayan serüveni
psikoloji okuyarak devam ederken günün
sonunda o dümeni tamamen İslam
motivasyon kaynağına birlikte spor
psikolog buna çevirdim Şimdi psikoloji
dediğimizde çoğumuzun aklına Tabii ki
klinik psikoloji geliyor Hatta psikoloji
öğrencilerin çoğu genelde klinik
psikolog olmayı düşünürler ama klip
soluk olmak böyle Benim tamamen hayatım
o tutabileceğim hayallerime Tam da
geçebilecek bir yerde değildi sanki yani
psikolog olduğunuza ne olur düzenli
seans larımız olur tek bir odada bunun
altını çizerek söylüyorum tek bir
mekanda danışanlara ilişkiniz başlar
devam eder ve sonlanır Tabii ki bu çok
uzun bir süreçten bahsediyorum şu ama
ben kendi hayatımı düşündüm de ben
gerçekten dinamik olmayı seven bir
çocuktum yani böyle üniversitede bile
derslerimi bilerek ard arda günlere
sıkıştırıp boş günlerimde bir şekilde
babamın da pilot olmasının avantajını
tabi kullanarak da mı seyahat ediyordu
var ya iki günlüğüne burada Japonya'da
Güney Afrika'ya falan gitmiştim bile var
öyle söyleyeyim ve bu kadar dinamik bir
insan olarak Aslında ben tek bir yerde
olmayı değil de çok farklı yerlerde
çeşitli yerlerde olmayı istiyordum Hatta
hayatımda her hafta bellibaş rutinlerin
olmasını ama aynı zamanda bu rutinin
dışına çıkabileceği Özgür alanlarında
olmasını Severdim işte Tam da bu yüzden
işim de de bu dinamik niye yeni şeyler
üretmeye Hatta ve hatta düzensizliği
ihtiyacım vardı tam da bunları
düşünürken klinik tarafımı ne kadar
istediğim gibi hayatımda olabilir diye
düşünmek beni araştırmalara gitti ve
dünyada o zamanlar oldukça yaygın olan
fakat Türkiye'de sesini böyle çok daha
yeni duymaya başlayan spor psikolojisi
ile tanıştım Tabi bu tanışmak o kadar
keyifli oldu ki benim için bir makale
gördüm o makalede sporcuların nasıl baş
edebileceklerini yarışma kaygısı nasıl
baş edebileceklerini dar bir şeyler
anlatılıyordu o an durdum bu Gitme Dedim
ki ya gerçekten tam olarak istediğim
buydu ve bunu buldum şimdi böyle
anlatıyorum ama tabii ki onu bulmak ve
sonrasındaki yolculuk gerçekten benim
için o kadar uzun zaman oldu ki Ama her
zaman o kadar benimsedim ki bu alanı
yani her hep böyle içinde olmak istedim
daha sonrasında baktığınızda polis polis
ne demek ki insanlar bana sorduğunda
birçok işten şu cevabı aldım işte Hadi
koçum benim Aslansın kaplansın sen be
yaparsın bunu gibi böyle gazlayıcı
cümleler varmış gibi ama aslında Tabii
ki bilimsel olarak asla böyle bir şey
yok bizim alanımız böyle birşey
kapsamıyor
Polis kolejine baktığınızda en genel
anlamıyla Aslında performansın
arttırılması hazır yükseltilmesi sportif
aktivitede kişisel duyum amacıyla daha
fazla psikolojik olarak tutarlı ve
sistematik olarak çalışılması anlamına
geliyor bu becerilerim yani o dediğimiz
damlama sistemi hiçbir şey bu işe
yaramıyor ve spor psikolojisindeki en
temel amaç şu bir Mental dayanıklılık
geliştirmek Ve biz bu Mental
dayanıklılığı yüksek konsantrasyon ya da
Stresle baş edebilme veya sağlam benlik
yapısı gibi birçok kavramla eşleştiriyor
Uz Tabi bunu oluşturmak ayrı bir mesele
ve biz Sports blogları olarak bu sürecin
içerisinde ne yapıyoruz zihinde
canlandırma nefes egzersizlere ya da
içsel konuşmalar gibi birçok Mental
strateji ile birlikte sporcuların
konsantrasyon motivasyon hedef belirleme
Özgüven gibi Mental becerilerini
güçlendirip onların kendi
performanslarının maksimumu bulma
yolculuklarında onlara eşlik ediyoruz
şimdi ben bu mesleğe başladığımda inanın
Yani o kadar yaygın değildi ki bu spor
psikolojisi
herhangi bir yere iş başvurusu
yapamıyorum ben var ya böyle gidip ben
kendim önce bir yerde kabul ettirmekten
önce o kadar çok federasyona markaya
sporcu sporcu ailesini sporcu kulübüne
ki şimdi konuşurken bile yoruluyorum
Devamlı böyle şey gibi spor psikolojisi
101 dersi verdim ya Spor biscotti nedir
ve ne işe yarar anlattım devamlı
insanlara kendimi anlatmak o kadar uzun
zamanımı aldı ki geri çevrildiği mi oldu
oldu mesleğimiz saygı duymadığını
hissettim Yakın çevremden bazen ya acaba
daha kolay para kazanacak bir işe mi
sahip olsan ya da daha düzenli bir şey
mi yapsam ne dersin diyenler de oldu bu
arada Ama ben gerçekten umutlu olduğum
şeyin içinde var olmayı her zaman çok
istedim
Çünkü benim hiçbir şekilde
psikolojisinden bir kazancım olmadığı
zamanlarda bile o ister motivasyonun hep
benimle birlikte olduğunu farkındaydım
ve süreç içerisinde zaman öğle vakti ki
ben en başlarda insanlara bakın ya bu
olan çok O bizim böyle bir çalışma
modelimiz var derken yavaş yavaş
insanlar Bu alanın önemini fark edip
şimdi bana gelip bizim böyle sporcumuz
var Acaba nasıl çalışırsınız bizimle
demeye başladılar şimdi tabi bu arada
sporcularla nasıl bir sistem içerisine
çalıştığımda oldukça merak edilen bir
sistem Çünkü sporcularla benim
çalışmalarım hem farklı mekanları hem
farklı dinamikleri hem de farklı
zamanları barındırıyor ki bizim çok
Alışık olduğumuz bir şey değil aslında
bu Bu benim sporlarla çalışmaları Mental
stilleri oluşturuyor ama aslında bu
Mental saticilarin uygulamalı alanda
nasıl işe yaradığını gözlemlemek de
benim bir görevim ve ben bu yüzden
sporcularla seyahat ediyorum ne
yapıyorum onlarla birlikte Tıpkı
antrenörleri Gibi antrenmanlarına
Gidiyorum kamplarına Gidiyorum birlikte
yemek yiyor ve aynı zamanda sohbet
ediyor oluyoruz düşer ki hayatta Hatta
bu şekilde birlikte zaman geçirmemiz ve
Ekip ruhu oluşturuyor olmamız süreç Ama
gerçekten performansa da pozitif
yansımasını görüyoruz Burada şimdi bunu
böyle çok içselleştirerek çok kendinden
emin bir şekilde anlatıyorum ama
mesleğin başındayken klinik psikoloji
yüksek lisansına öğrendiklerimden inanın
tam bu şekilde zıt bir şeydi bu çünkü
Normalde klinik tarafta sizin danışanla
ilişkiniz tek bir odada çerçevelenir
orada devam eder ama burada devamlı
başka mekanlar var fakat süreç ise fark
ettim ki Aslında her ne kadar farklı
mekanlarda bir ilişkimiz olsa da biz
yine o mekanlar farklılaştığı noktada
ilişkimize kendi sınırlarını
çerçevesinden düzenliyoruz O yüzden
bizim yaptığımız o birlikte vakit
geçirdiğimiz şeyler asla bizim çok daha
fazla işimize yarıyor ve bize avantaj
sağlıyor Evet şimdi ben metal satışı
dedim ise buralarda O yüzden tahmin
edersiniz ki mesleğin en önemli özelliği
metacity ciler ama burada bir tane
örneği vereyim zihinde canlandırma
Aslında benim en yoğun olarak kullandım
stratejilerin başında geliyor şimdi
zihinde canlandırma dediğimde öyle
dışarıda şey laflar geziyor ya işte
lütfen gözünüzü kapatın böyle nefesinizi
alın ve çok tatlı bir şey hayal edin
hemen rahatlayacaksınız ya da bir şey
hayal edin işte üç güne kadar
gerçekleşir kesin ya bu Tabii ki böyle
bir saçma bir şey diyeceğim de
canlandırma daha çok zihinde canlandırma
bizim için gerçeğin taklidi demek ve Biz
beş duyu organımızla sporcuların daha da
gerçeği yakın bir şekilde zihinde
canlandırma yapmalarını sağlamaya
çalışıyoruz onların motivasyonunu
arttırmak özgüvenini geliştirmek ya da
birçok adaptasyonu sağlayabilmek için
zihinde canlandırma en çok kullandığımız
yöntemlerin başında geliyor
borama benim gerçekten zihinde
canlandırma da en çok dikkatimi çeken
hoşuma giden şey İyi ki bence sizin de
hoşunuza gidecek Şimdi tenisçi düşünün
antrenmanda servis atıyorsun
Evet şimdi tenisi servis atarken nasıl
ki belirli kol kas grupları çalışıyorsa
uyarılıyor sa Aslında zihninde bu
servisi attığında da aynı seviyede
olmasa da belli bir seviyede beyninde Bu
kol kas gruplarının bir şekilde uyarıldı
tespit edilmiş Yani
bilgilere baktığımızda Sporcular
fiziksel olarak antrenmanların yanında
ne kadar zihinde canlandırma yaparlarsa
o kadar çok uyarılmaya birazcık da
destek olmuş oluyorlar
Bart Abi özellikle pandemi döneminde Bu
arada zihinde canlandırma yürütün de
ekleyen sporcuların antrenmanlara geri
döndükten sonra antrenmansız gibi hisset
memelerinin ve çok kolay adapte olmaları
da sebebi bu oldu burada Ben ilk başta
Yani ilk seansı yaptığımda sporculara
sorduğumda inanın yüzde doksanı zihinde
canlandırma biliyor ama sadece mükemmel
performansı canlandırmak için
kullanıyorlar fakat bizim için bu
yöntemin en gizli kahramanı şu
sporcuların en çok kaygılandıran ları ve
baş etmekte o zorlandıkları senaryoları
canlandırarak o canlandırmanın
içerisinde zihinlerinde onlara başaçek
yöntemler bulmaları şimdi bunun en güzel
oyunu ile ben size dünya şampiyonu Ayşe
Begüm onbaşı ile olan çalışmalarımızdan
vereyim Biz Ayşe'yle çok uzun zamandır
çalışıyoruz ve o Gerçekten hem fiziksel
hem de Mental antrenmanlara inanılmaz
önemseyen bir sporcu Siz Ayşe podyumda
görüyorsunuz bir buçuk dakikalık bir
performans sergiliyor
var Yani hepimizin hayatına baktığımızda
aslında bir buçuk dakika çok kısa Belki
fark etmediğimiz ya da çok sıradan bir
zaman dilimi Ama bu göz açıp kapayıncaya
kadar giden zaman dilimi için Ayşe
binlerce kez kendi performansını
binlerce kez yarışmanın bütün
detaylarını zihninde canlandırıyor biz
onun performansını parçalara bölerek ya
da daha gerçeğe yakın olsun diye
canlandırmalar da zaman tutarak veya
performansında kullandığı müziği aynı
şekilde arka planda çalarak ve onun en
korktuğu ya da baş etmekte en zorlandığı
senaryoları ona maruz bırakarak bir çok
çeşitli zihinde canlandırma yapıyoruz ve
bizim ikimizin de
canlandırmaları en çok sevdiğim şey şu
bu arada bu sonsuz kere hata yapma
şansın olması Çünkü o bir buçuk dakikada
hata yapma şansı yok ve biz mükemmele
ulaşmaya çalışıyoruz ama mükemmel
çalışma yolculuğunda sonsuz kere hata
yapabilir ve bizim ona verdiğimiz bu
hataya tolerans sayesinde Aslında ne
oluyor hem hataya bakış açısı değişiyor
hem de süreç içerisinde hatayla çok daha
işlevsel bir şekilde başarabiliyor
bu
günlük Hatta da farkındaysanız Yani
çoğumuz aslında Ayşe gibi kendimize veya
bir başkasıyla yarışıyoruz kendi
dayanıklı ımızı geliştirmeye çalışıyoruz
bazen işte iş hayatımızda yöneticimiz
indir hiç anlamadığı na ya da bize
verdiği herhangi bir pozisyonu çok fazla
hak etmediğimizi düşünüyoruz ya da hak
ettiğimizi tam alamadığımız düşünüyoruz
tıpkı bir voleybolcunun ya da
basketbolcunun antrenöründen bir türlü
hak ettiği süreye alamaması gibi ya da
bazen o kadar güzel bir an yaşıyoruz ki
o anın tadını çıkarmak yerine geçmişte
yaptığımız bir hata ya takılı kalıp
kendimize o hatadan dolayı kızarak ya da
Geleceğe dair devamlı senaryolar
üreterek o anı kaybediyoruz da aynı bir
tenisçinin Bir önceki puan da yaptığı
hataya takılı kalıp aslında şu anki puan
da hem geçmişi telafi edebileceğini hem
de geleceğim maksimum şekilde şekil
verebileceğini unutması gibi ipi
hepimizin hayatımızda kendi kontrol
alanlarını yaratıp başa baş edemediğimiz
faktörlerle yeniden bir baş etme
yöntemleri belirlemek şu an odaklanıp
asıl hayattaki etki alanınıza
artırabileceğini fark etmek ve zaman
zaman insanların bize yansıttığı duygu
ve düşünceleri her zaman içselleştirmek
yerine birazcık da Onları dışarıda
bırakıyor olmak bizim günlük hayattaki
Mental Kasım'da her zaman güçlendirir
tabi size burada bir sihirli değnekten
bahsetmiyorum Ama bu kullanabileceğiniz
istikrarlı şekilde kullanabileceğiniz
Mental stratejiler ve bu sürece olan
inancınız size süreç içerisinde adım
adım bu dayanıklı geliştiğini
hissettirir bir
ya Ben çocukken Bir hayal kurdum denize
gerçekten çok büyük yerlere gelmek
istiyordum Hatta olimpiyatlarda ülkemi
temsil etmek istiyordum şimdi gerçekçi
olayım her ne kadar milli olmuş olsam da
bence o performansla ve o günün
şartlarıyla çok demin bir hayal değildi
zaten 18 yaşına tenis bıraktıktan sonra
bu hayat tamamen sonuçlanmıştı ama söyle
sanmışım
Çıktığın bu yolculuk sayesinde Aslında
ben hayalimi bir şekilde dönüştürmüş tüm
Çünkü artık ekran başında heyecanlanarak
izlemek yerine İki sene sonra Türkiye
modern toplum Federasyonu ile birlikte
Ben 2024 yılında Paris olimpiyatlarında
ülkemizi bir spor psikoloğu olarak
temsil edeceğim sanırım hem geçmişime
hem bugünüme hem de yarına verdiğim en
güzel hediye boğuldu teşekkür ederim